welcome back to our break the cycle
time management hour if there's one
place i like to save time it is in the
kitchen and our next guest is about to
show us an
easy and healthy recipe that takes just
minutes to make
he is a james beard award-winning chef
and best-selling author
i can't believe he's here i'm freaking
out it's rocco de spirito
i'm the one who's freaking out you gotta
let me freak out
how are you how are you nice to see you
i watched you on tv
i love food that's why i sit and stare
at food shows and study chefs and have
cookbook club and i'm a big collector
but that has nothing to do with my real
life
gotta go on the move kids work life
messiness and i feel like a place where
you can get really short changed is what
you're putting into your body with food
because if you don't have the time to
cook
you end up grabbing boxed things that's
true so here's one
one option for you this is a really
simple shrimp dish it's really healthy
it's only about 350 calories
the normal version would be in the 1800
calorie range yeah and it's
it's out of one of crazy healthy books
so you start with a hot pan
so one of the tips for going real fast
in the kitchen is
high heat we're always working with high
heat at home most people are afraid to
use high heat because
it feels uncomfortable you know there's
radiant heat in your on your body
well i think also people who fear their
time management
in the kitchen when they even have the
luxury of time high heat means like if
you're not super on it it's gonna burn
and they're right and so you have to be
super on it for at least
two to three minutes so give yourself
two to three minutes be completely
active and focused
and you'll produce something that's
really good that you'll enjoy for an
hour we've got
jumbo shrimp notice the tails are taken
off completely
that's a pet peeve of mine i don't know
how you feel everyone's got their
opinion
i don't like to eat those very sharp uh
tails
i can tell you this i'm a really good
de-veiner
oh good uh and you start by having a hot
pan which we have
you put oil in your hot pan you watch
the oil get wavy
once it starts waving you know it's hot
so it's already smoking by the way which
is amazing so
now because of the smoke we're going to
have to go a little fast okay so we're
going to season
in the pan and you're going to see that
i'm moving a little quickly now
i want to make sure i grab the heat and
don't let the heat escape before
i finish cooking the shrimp meanwhile in
another pan we've got broccoli rabe
which is
my number one two or three favorite
vegetable it's one of the healthiest
vegetables on the planet now
pepper and salt again on the top while
it's in the pan
and you can see that the shrimp's
already starting to turn paste
pink in cooking protein
is the weight to flip it and flip it
once
ruled does that apply to shrimp as well
it can apply to shrimp so shrimp
shrimp that are this big and expensive
and uh have been blotted dried and taken
care of really well
um you want to make sure you treat
nicely oh wait so a
you gotta blot it dry because that's
when you cook scallops we blotted
in the beginning we used paper towels
why does mine not look as good as yours
rocco
how did i scrape the shrimp so the
shrimp the shrimp should come out
uh when they're about halfway cooked so
they should go on this plate
so when they're halfway cooked about
half way cooked they're gonna keep
cooking so just slide them right out
like that
and put a little more oil in the pan and
we're gonna make the sauce we're going
to
use pepper jelly which is
it's one of my favorite shortcut foods
pepper jelly goes in the pan
it's going to melt immediately it's
basically a concentration of flavor
um that would normally take hours or
at least 20 minutes to create if you're
reducing pepper juice and sauteing
onions and all that
we're going to add see how you got
sizzle sizzle's really good by the way
i love lemon
let's add lemon juice about how much the
whole thing is the whole thing that's
not how much that's about a lemon that's
about a whole lemon that's a whole lemon
yes and now the butter normally the
butter would be a
you know a stick or a half a stick it's
a small amount
just enough to get the emulsification
it's a little pot of butter
so look at how it's gotten nice and
thick and it's shiny
and it looks like a sauce already add a
little salt and pepper
taste it maybe taste it i hardly ever
looked down at my pan so proud rocco
you should be very proud of what you're
getting done right well i'm just
your little student so let's start by
plating the broccoli rabe
okay we'll leave the shrimp to reduce in
the pan and get sticky and gooey and
glazey see this is why i love a tongue
tongues are fantastic they really are
underrated go in and you fork lift it
over
exactly right onto the plate that's over
there yeah then the shrimp should be
perfect so give them a toss
it's like trying to lift up a buick
that's good
i'm making this pan work for me oh
that's a good idea yeah just toss it out
exactly oh my gosh it's time to taste
this it looks pretty amazing right i
mean just look up get up and be making
nice i'm like
let's do this
oh good oh my gosh
so good so good
finger damn it's like six ingredients by
the way so good
oh my goodness it's so simple by the way
tell me about this
stunning bread that you have so we all
love to eat bread
you know i'm a bit of a health nut so i
created a bread that was
made out of nuts and seeds no gluten
it's all organic it's vegan
you can eat it yeah yeah please you can
eat it all you want
uh of course i sell it on my website
shameless plug
all the good stuff none of the bad stuff
so you can eat bread without feeling
guilty beauty shot
rocco beauty shot all right literally
i want to take this
[Music]
i um
uh this is so incredible that
i really can't even handle it rocco
thank you so much be sure to pick up
some of rocco's nut and seed bread
we're going to have it on the website so
you can find his books that would be
nice
to his site the bread everything thank
you so much we'll be right back
thank you
you